Yeah. So in 2007,
I was 13 years old and we didn't have anything to eat anymore.
So we were thinking, what do we do? You know,
there were tons of people dying from starvation,
and I was fortunate enough to live on the border town of North Korea.
So I was able to see the lights coming from China's side.
So if you look at the satellite photos of North Korea,
it is like the literary darkest place on earth.
You don't have interesting nights.
So I was looking at China and then wondering maybe if I go where the lights
were, I might find something to eat.
[Inaudible].
I'm Dave Rubin, and this is the Rubin report.
Joining me today is a human rights activist author of in order to
live a North Korean girl's journey to freedom and someone that I'm honored to
call a friend beyond me park, welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you so much for having me. It's a real honor to be on your show.
Um, I'm thrilled to have you, can I call us friends?
We've only hung out one time and just in the last few weeks,
but I feel that we are long lost friends.
Definitely. I've been following,
you're almost like stuck in here for the last three, four years.
I've been to your show with the Joe Jordan Peterson in Chicago,
and I wasn't even one of the audience. So yeah.
Well, I, I do consider you a friend and I, and I'm thrilled.
You're here because your story is,
is just absolutely incredible.
And you've become a fighter for so many of the things that,
that this show is about.
So let's just start at the beginning for people that don't know you.
Uh, let's just, let's just do your biography. Just,
just tell me your story and then we'll go from there.
Right? Yeah.
So I was born in the Northern part of North Korea in end of
1993.
So that was right after Soviet union collapsed and North Korean regime stopped
providing ration to the people. So because in the socialist system,
the trading is illegal. And if the government doesn't give you food,
what do you do? We staff death. And unfortunately, that's when I was born,
when North Korea began going into this thing called like the, you know,
I mean the worst family in human history in 21st century,
I was going in North Korea. I had a father,
my mom and my sister in a very ordering hassle word.
And I had no clue that North Korea was, uh, you know,
her making the one where the country is truly isolated.
We don't even know what isolation means.
And growing up in North Korea, of course it was, uh, you know,
we didn't have a word for love. We didn't have a role for Liberty.
We didn't have words for a lot of, uh, things.
So you were 13 when your family decided to leave
North Korea, is that right?
Yeah. That's me gay from North Korea.
It wasn't like you're getting a passport. Yeah.
Right. Escape escape is a much better word.
So can you just tell us a little bit about what that was like?
Yeah. So in 2007,
I was 13 years old and we didn't have anything to eat anymore.
So we were thinking, what do we do? You know,
there were tons of people dying from starvation.
And I was fortunately enough to live on the border town of North Korea.
So I was able to see the lights coming from China side.
So if you look at the satellite photos of North Korea,
it is like the literary darkest place on earth.
You don't have interesting nights.
So I was looking at China and then wondering,
maybe if I go over the lights or I might find something to eat,
and that was the motivation why we risk our life to escape from China. I mean,
North Korea.
Yeah. And your story of, of actually how you did it is pretty incredible.
So you have to tell that to everyone.
Where we, I was,
we had to cross a frozen Weaver to China and they are like every
10 meters, the border guards with the machine guns.
Now the North Korea buried the landmines and electrify the wire fences
to prevent people to stay. However, when we were escaping,
we had a person, a human trafficker,
she sold us two Chinese human traffickers.
And that's how we were able to safely cross the border to China.
Did you guys know what was going to happen to you? I mean,
I know you were just a kid, but did, did your parents at that point? No.
You're being sold to human traffickers and I know you'll,
you'll tell what happened next,
but did your parents have any idea what that meant or, or it was just like,
we have to get there no matter what is about to happen to us.
So it wasn't like my parents deciding it.
My sister escaped a few days before me and I was in the hospital
and you know, North Korean hospitals, we don't of course have x-rays or nothing.
The doctor is like, no touching my tummy and told me,
you might have some bursting of appendix and we have to operate on you this
afternoon. And they'll of course, call my belly without any anesthesia.
And they realized it wasn't like appendix.
It was just malnutrition and infection. So I couldn't go with my sister,
but she left me a note to say, go find this lady.
And she will help you to go to China. And when I saw that letter,
I told my mom like, mom, you got to come me to me.
I couldn't leave my father who was very sick. So it was, uh,
I took my mom to get me in the mirror, crossing that river.
We didn't even know the word human trafficking. Like it wasn't something,
a concept I was aware. Right. Thing. It's like,
I didn't even question why the person was a happiness.
I was so desperate and I wasn't, he didn't really matter if me,
if I was only a kid in China, my fate in North Korea was death. Anyway.
So really matter what it was.
Yeah. Do you think your mom knew what,
what was about to happen when you got there to China?
No clue. She also had abs, so in North Korea, we don't,
we have like one channel on TV,
which is all propaganda and we don't have internet. And there is only,
we don't have one newspaper.
We do not have any else of information coming in.
So I never even seen the map of the word.
I had no clue the different races existed.
I did not even know what Africa was in North Korea.
The regime taught me that I was,
in some ways they didn't tell me that I was Asian.
So I didn't really know how many countries existed or none of the us or
North Korea. So she, of course, in the nano,
we just went there and found out what it was.
Yeah. Okay.
So you get to China and I think you probably thought you were going to
be safe, but that's not exactly how that worked out either.
Yeah. So I was 13 and crossing is frozen.
We were with mom and the human traffic we're us to go there.
And as soon as the first thing I was seeing was my mom waved involve me
and I was 13. And in North Korea, we don't have any sex education.
So I didn't even need to know what that was.
Didn't even know that was a rape horrible.
And I couldn't believe what was happening. And then they told us later,
they were like negotiating our price in front of us.
And they talk about a slave markets exactly like that.
They stored in my mouth for one $65 in 21st century right
now. And I was above $200.
They bought me because I was a Virgin and I was young and they sold us
separately to different human traffickers. Right.
And then what I feel like this whole interview, I could just say to you,
and then what, and then what, because it's such a, it's such a series of things,
but I think it's important for people to really understand all these steps.
So as soon as they were separating mom and me, and, you know,
even I was like 13 mine, I didn't care. They were like,
they want to make more money out of us than splitting us.
They told us to me to another human trafficker, he was like a hand Chinese.
And he of course tried to rape me. And I was trying to kill myself.
I was, I couldn't take it anymore. So I was trying to kill myself. And he said,
if I become his mistress and he would become buying my mom
and bring my family to me, I was in a way,
very lucky that I found the trafficker who wanted to help me that way.
So at third, and I thought like, okay, if I become his mistress,
I can sell my family. And I get to become his mistress.
He raped me and did it bring my money back?
He bought my mom from the farmer he sold to.
So because of the U2 one child policy in China right now,
there are more than 30 million men cannot find the wives.
North Korean women are IP demanded by these men.
And so there's a sexual slave STEM.
Did. Did, did you think your life was better at that point? Like,
did you feel better now, suddenly you had seen a wider world,
but horrific things were happening to you. I mean,
the rape of your mom rape of you, you were, it's not that you were free.
Like what, what did you think at the time in terms of like, was,
were things better? Was it worth going?
I stopped feeling things. The thing through my therapy,
that's like my struggle and not trying to feel again, like at 13,
somehow I just learned not to fear. So it wasn't like I was thinking about,
am I happy? Or like, it wasn't like that.
It was like every second of a survivor and trying to
get called by Chinese authority because they were like looking for us like every
second.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about
international issues, instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our international playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.